y va a ser una sesión más de la
organización de estados américanos pero
el embajador de nicaragua ante la oea
arturo mcfields se rebeló contra su
propio gobierno tomó la palabra el día
de hoy en nombre de más de 177 presos
políticos y más de 350 personas que han
perdido la vida en mi país desde el año
2018 denunciar la dictadura de mi país
no es fácil
pero seguía guardando silencio y
defender lo indefendible
es imposible mcfields en el cargo desde
octubre de 2021 tenía que liderar el
proceso para que nicaragua abandonase la
oea salida después de que el organismo
no reconociese el resultado de las
elecciones del pasado mes de noviembre
sin embargo el gobierno reaccionó con un
comunicado asegura que su representante
ante la oea es el embajador en eeuu
francisco camps el hooker el señor
arturo mcfields no nos representa por lo
cual ninguna declaración suya tiene
validez rápidamente tanto la oea como
diplomáticos de otros países de américa
latina' aplaudieron a maxfield también a
anthony blinken secretario de estado de
eeuu hoy el embajador de nicaragua ante
la oea máxima y renunció en protesta
denunciando el régimen de ortega murillo
por su historial de opresión y contra
los derechos humanos
felicitamos el coraje de marfil al dar
voz a los millones de compatriotas
nicaragüenses que esperan un retorno a
la democracia
esta semana la ex candidata presidencial
cristiana chamorro fue condenada a 8
años de
es una de las al menos 46 figuras
opositoras detenidas en el pasado año
que llevaron a eeuu y la unión europea a
decir que la última elección de daniel
ortega fue ilegítima